- Politicians have run
against the elite media
for a long time.
I mean think about George Wallace,
the way he campaigned
when he ran for president.
He would point out the
New York Times reporter
or the Washington Post reporter.
And that has been a favorite tactic
of many politicians over time.
What is different is that it is now coming
from the president of the United States
on a very regular basis.
I mean it is part of the stock
and trade of his approach
to de-legitimize any effort on the part
of mainstream media or
whatever you wanna call it
to do the kind of
journalism that we have done
for a long, long time.
We have not changed our approach.
We have not changed our standards.
If anything, our standards
are probably higher today
because the consequences of being wrong.